Welcome Angelina Jolie.
Hey
Hello.
You play Thena.
- I do.
Yes.
We will talk to you both.
So you both--
I can't talk to her
Are you leaving us now?
No, I mean if you want me
to stay, I'll stay, but--
[LAUGHING]
- Talk to her.
Here, let's please swap
places, at the very least.
No, it's like boy,
girl, boy, girl.
OK, all right.
Boy, girl, boy, girl.
All right
So I have a question for
you, which actually both of you
can answer.
Something that you
have beautifully
talked about in interviews,
is having your heart
be a part of the
projects that you do,
and how that's important.
So how did you connect to Thena?
What did you find there?
And for you what did you
find in Kingo that you
personally connected with?
I think mine is
going to be easier.
[LAUGHS] I was thinking
like, his insanity, for you.
[LAUGHING]
He's like Kingo is so big, and
you're actually quite humble.
So I actually think you.
You know, for me, I
was, yeah I just sort
of took parts of myself.
And took away any sort of worry.
He's a guy who's
really unworried.
I think being Kingo is
pretty easy, it's pretty fun.
What was it?
- I love Kingo.
I have, you know
I've wanted to talk
to you about Thena for a long
time after watching the movie.
Seeing you create
the character there,
I've become the interviewer.
I know, It was like, all
right, like take over the mic.
It's so, it's, why
don't you talk about that?
Because I want to hear it?
So did you, I thought I
was trying to avoid mine.
Oh you want to avoid it?
We're not going to let
you out of the answer.
Well, she's, my
heart, it's a hard one.
She's, she has, this
is the first time
I've talked about it.
She has post-traumatic
stress disorder,
she's a little uneven.
And I think she's
struggling with a lot
and she's not sure she can
be what she needs to be.
She's not sure
she's strong enough,
she's not sure she can
still defend her family.
Well for both of
you, I'm curious.
You know, you both have played
so many different parts.
And you've had so many
superheroes, or like you know,
strong characters
that you played.
Is there anything
that really connected
with you about your
character, that you
really connected with the most?
Or that you learned about
yourself in playing this role?
I guess it's that
fragility, that it's OK to be
both fragile and also strong.
It can go, it can
be the same person.
I really, you know, saw
that watching Angie work.
Because you know, I'm a very
verbal person, the characters
that play are very verbal.
And the character
that she created,
she conveys through her
physicality so well.
It really was inspiring and
intimidating for me to watch.
You really created
this person who
says so much without really
having to use their words,
you know.
It really, it was
really special to watch.
And then to see it come
together on screen,
she's so good in the movie.
Can you tell we
both are obsessed
with each other characters?
[LAUGHING]
So we're hoping
in the sequel, we
actually think our characters
are very good like,
sparring partners.
I think so.
Because we're almost
polar opposites.
That's right.
But yet, they're both a
little like, out there, so.
That's right.
I think we would make a--
They'd be a good time.
Yeah, great pairing.
That's exactly right.
I hope that Kevin Feige is
listening to this right now.
Because you both have
some very good ideas.
Thank you.
There you go, Kevin.
Well that's what
happens when you have
an Academy Award-nominated
screenwriter
and Academy Award winner.
You're both such
wonderful artists.
My last question is, you
know as full artists,
for you with the script, and the
writing, and the way the story
came together.
What did you most appreciate
about that and the themes
that it has?
Family.
We're a family.
And it's and it's been too
long coming, this family.
Yeah, I think
that's exactly right.
And we're a global family, you
know, we look like the world.
For so long, we've
seen superheroes
that have looked like a small
percentage of the world.
This superhero team
looks like the world.
And I also, you know in
the last year and a half,
we've sort of learned that
we are on the same Earth.
And we all share
the same problems,
like these boundaries and
stuff, they're not as important.
These borders are not
as important as what
we really have in common.
And this movie
really gets to that.
It really gets to
the truth of the fact
that we're all on
this rock together,
and we have to take
care of each other.
That is a wonderful way
to end this interview.
Thank you both so
much for stopping
by, talking live to the fans.
We appreciate it.
Have a wonderful time tonight.
Thank you, thanks for coming.